The jogan
Experience how much does the Cyber truck
weigh uh dep configuration but it's
about I know 7,000 six there's different
versions but six six 7,000 it's it's
like similar to like it's a heavy truck
like a Ford F250 or something like that
yeah and
it because of uh all of the the the
metal and the weight and everything like
that but with the engines that you have
it's still the 0 to 60 is pretty bizarre
right it's like 35 or something like
that we're aiming to get the 0 to 60
below 3 seconds below three yes wow for
the you know the beast mode version so
we've got a beast mode version that's uh
um so there's there's there's well I
don't want to give it all away right now
but um there are there are three
demonstrations one of them peopleware of
which is uh you know emptying a Tommy
gun into the side of the car um a sh gun
45 and a 9 mil and no penetrations wow
and that's that come it comes that way
from the factory can I try it with an
arrow yeah it'll be fine you think so I
mean I bet I can get in a crossbow might
I have a 90 lb compound bow that shoots
520 grain arrows at 300 feet per second
with a I think an razor sharp Broadhead
we try it right now if you want I wish I
had it with me
um I don't is it at your house or
something yeah should we send someone to
go get it we can do the demo tonight
that would be interesting I'll maybe
I'll drive back with an arrow sticking
out of my car I bet I can get in there
okay I'll bet you can't really yeah I'll
bet your dollar
damn I'd like Dam I think I think if you
have a a crossbow that's with with
enough Force you might a crossbow the
thing about a crossbow is the bolt even
though it's very fast it's not going to
be nearly as heavy you you won't have as
many grains you can make a a heavy
crossbow bolt you could yeah but
generally uh crossbow bolts are
considerably lighter they're much
smaller you know and they they they're
much faster they're they're moving at
like 400 500 feet per second
easy yeah I mean the the thing that
matters is kind of the energy per unit
area so
um so interesting like like a like a 9
mil or 45 which is basically sort of a
10 mil um the the the 45 is they're
roughly the same but the the 45 actually
slightly worse penetration than a 9 mil
you know what I just realized I do have
some
broadheads I do have some broadheads and
I have a less powerful bow but I have an
80 PB bow back there I think we should
do it absolutely okay when you want to
do it right now yeah I can do it right
now let's do it right now let's find now
[__] yeah let's do it
sick we'll be right back
I bring it
back just don't don't you know let the
Arrow come back
in I mean just beware of
ricochets you might want to do it at a
slight
angle
you know what I
[Applause]
mean this blew the blew the arrow
apart yeah flatten the tip of the
arrow look at the tip of the Broadhead
that's
impressive hey
cutie thank you well now we
know so uh we uh just shot an arrow into
it and it barely scratched it barely
scratched it yeah it was probably moving
275 ft a second that was a 525 grain is
arrow with uh yeah even more than that
cuz it had the 125 grain head so that
was 500 45 grains that's impressive yeah
very impressive it just destroyed the
Broadhead Broadhead flattened at the tip
and then the arrow blew apart yeah
amazing yeah it's uh like I said you
could um we have a cool video we'll show
at the Handover event next month which
is emptying an entire magazine of a
Tommy Gun which I think it's like on the
order of 50 rounds uh just you're just
going full L Capone you know like on the
side of the car shotgun 9 M 45 and you
built it like this just for fun well I
mean uh cuz it's cooler I mean cuz you
can you know uh trucks are supposed to
be tough right yeah so is your truck
bulletproof no Mine mine's definitely
not exactly and if I shot mine with my
my bow would go right through it 100%
100% if if you if you shoot any normal
car unlike in the movies where people
hide behind car doors uh cardor is
basically a very thin mild steel uh so
uh if you
if you shoot a gun at through through
like a regular truck it'll go out it'll
go through both doors so
um it's you can't hide behind a a car
door like they do in the movies you know
the back way back in the day dating
myself but the The A Team where they
would like you know there'd be like
bullets flying everywhere and they'd be
hiding behind the car door right that
doesn't work um but it doesn't a cyber
truck